what up space fam golden here from anime
outbreak i'm back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story and oh boy was this
chapter ever crazy we are here to
discuss none other than chapter 1049
called the world you wish for in this
one we got the exciting conclusion of
the awakened luffy versus the awakened
kaido fight the end of wano is finally
here it's insane stuff we find out more
juicy details about kaido's backstory
momo finally shows us what he's made of
and we get to find out what luffy's
great wish slash goal is which i really
didn't think would be revealed so soon
so make sure to stay tuned for this epic
legendary chapter that will most
definitely go down in history and is
arguably the biggest chapter
ever if you like seeing one piece
chapter reviews like this one on their
channel i want to keep them coming you
know what to do smash that like button
with no mercy until it explodes with
fireworks fireworks that signify nothing
less than wano's newfound freedom be a
smashing pirate king rather than a
passing orochi if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece chapter reviews
and updates now i want to thank this
light for sponsoring this video are you
as obsessed with badass mythical gods as
i am then this light is the game for you
this light is the stylish urban
mythological rpg you have longed for set
in the near future with a stylish urban
mythological theme this light is a
visually stunning story of heroes you
have god waifus like valkyrie bryn and
just straight up badass gods like anubis
drew who must be the coolest butler i've
ever seen you build your epic team and
fight enemies while enjoying the
stunning audio visual experience i
really got into the hype building
soundtrack myself the unique pop fantasy
art style stands out and i love all of
the striking diverse character designs
all of them have individuality each
character is derived from one of four
mythologies which have their own
personality and style i also really like
the chill gameplay experience you don't
have to flip the phone back and forth
between vertical and horizontal because
this game is designed for a vertical
screen so what are you waiting for go
through my link to support my channel
right now and start your mythical
journey with this light use promo code
join this slide to get awesome limited
awards now without further ado let's
jump into its spoilers and all as
mentioned this chapter is called the
world you wish for and it starts where
we left off with the main event itself
the luffy vs kaido fight we're talking
luffy's gear 5 monkey god giant fist
attack versus kaido's awakened flame
body kaido thinks luffy will melt but of
course luffy's haki training this arc
will allow him to actually attack
without physically touching kaido and
thus without getting burned so watch out
akainu or akainu however you want to say
it we're coming for you next we're told
this is a fierce hockey clash who will
prevail i read this narrator note
because it's setting this up as a battle
or clash between two masters of haki
pretty much meaning that if luffy wins
he's really proven his mastery of hockey
to the point where it even outclasses a
yonkos very big stuff and it makes me
feel like we're probably closer to the
end of one piece than a lot of people
realize hard to believe we're at the
point where luffy r luffy from the east
blue is about to beat the living yonko
with the highest bounty it's insane
absolutely insane to think about anyways
we see luffy punching kaido's open mouth
kaido says well played as luffy is
clearly focused probably wincing from
the heat of kaido's flames and the force
of his attack kaido actually looks like
the one with the advantage at this point
because as luffy looks worried and is
wincing kaido's expression looks more
like a calm smile he says he has to hand
it to luffy for coming this far but he
also says luffy will never be able to
change the world then as kaido looks to
be in the winning position based on his
calmness and ability to chit-chat in the
middle of this we jump to his flashback
i think we were all expecting the
flashback eventually and i even
mentioned in the last chapter that if we
jump into a flashback in this chapter
this probably will be the attack to
finish kaido off because you know we
need that backstory before kaido
actually gets defeated and we get it
here we see a 10 year old kaido being
called the strongest soldier around and
he clearly loved fighting saying he's
still itching for more we're then told
it's 46 years ago in the kingdom of
vodka a name which of course goes well
with kaido who loves to do stuff
associated with vodka kaido who is now
59 was 13 years old at this point we're
told vodka kingdom has no choice but to
wage war since the loot they acquire is
their only means of paying the celestial
tribute i like that the celestial
dragons are brought into this because it
positions luffy and kaido in a sort of
similar position where they're both
enemies of the oppressing celestials who
represent the lack of freedom it
suggests that kaido could very well grow
fond of luffy and maybe even want to
help him in his end goal of liberating
the world from the celestial dragons and
the world government and even though
luffy hasn't ever perfectly verbalized
it like that it seems pretty clear
that's where the whole sun god luffy
thing is headed but back to the
backstory and they say if we fail to pay
the tribute we stand to lose our
standing in the world kaido says why the
celestial dragons get to boss them
around and then they just shut kaido up
for questioning the way things are in
this case he's very reminiscent of a
young luffy and has straightforward
uncorrupted thinking then kaido is
betrayed he's offered up to the navy by
his kingdom who can't handle him kaido
is already like over twice the size of
the navy men around him who are trying
to restrain him with chains it's further
revealed that the kingdom did it because
in exchange for handing over such a
strong dude they'd be guaranteed a seat
at the next reverie kaido resists
angrily saying he's not a political
bargaining chip although it's obviously
not cool what they did in the kingdom's
defense they wanted according to this to
enlist kaido into the army so it's not
like they were sending him to his death
or to live out his whole life in prison
or anything like that but kaido started
running away eventually and then became
wanted we're shown one wanted poster
which states his bounty was 70 million
at the time notably that's more than
luffy's first bounty of 30 million after
he beat buggy don creek and arlong it's
clear that this capture followed by
escape followed by capture and so on was
a common occurrence we see marines being
confused saying they already caught him
did he really escape again and i love
this part one says i heard kaido gets
caught on purpose when he's hungry and
another says a prison ship isn't a
buffet this is great legend building for
kaido since even as a kid he was so
confident he could escape the marines
that he'd pretend to be captured to fill
his hunger knowing he could just escape
again later it helps explain why kaido
was caught so many times too 44 years
ago we see a 15 year old kaido on
hachinosu blackbeard's current hangout
in this pirate's paradise we see that
kaido just knocked out another pirate
people remarked that he's so strong and
how can he only be 15. then we see the
legend himself whitebeard furthermore
this is 30 year old whitebeard such a
treat seeing him young and imperfect
health in this flashback he asks and i'm
guessing this is still 15 year old kaido
if he wants to be a pirate and tells him
that rox wants to meet him we're told
kaido joined and people thought the
rock's pirates were unstoppable now
after all they had rocks a young white
beard big mom and kaido among many
others a part of me really wishes we saw
why kaido decided to join but oh well
i'm glad we got this much guess oda
doesn't want to reveal too much about
rocks yet they go to god valley and we
see the reaction of other pirates
shocked that the rock's pirates have
fallen despite all the monsters they
have on their crew they heard a marine
called garp beat em imagine getting full
credit for beating all of these
legendary pirates it's no wonder garp is
viewed as the hero of the marines
another pirate thinks as i always
thought personally that their infighting
did them in since none of them were team
players that's the beauty of luffy's
crew they're team players and that will
probably be emphasized as they go up
against blackbeard's crew who were all
brought in for their power and as a
result in all likelihood won't get along
nearly as well we even see a younger big
mom screaming don't mess with me where
did you go kaido this might be a nod to
around when she saved him by giving him
his op fruit god valley was set to take
place 38 years ago when kaido was 21
years old the layout of the manga panels
in this chapter suggest kaido might have
joined the rox pirates as i mentioned at
15 years old which would mean he was
with them for a significant six years
those must have been some crazy years
that i want to know all about at some
point then 10 years after that incident
by which i assume they mean 10 years
after god valley or when kaido is 31 he
runs into kurozumi higurashi she tells
him that since that incident kaido is
now known as the embodiment of brutality
he has his crew
and king is already there as his first
mate she tells him if you study history
humans have always resorted to brutality
aka cruel and violent behavior to solve
the world's problems it's then pointed
out that humans are just like any other
animal survival of the fittest is our
nature kaido says he couldn't agree more
and now he has his facial hair it said
from now on everything will revolve
around the former members of the rock's
crew and truly three out of four of the
yonko were from the rock's pirates and
each of them definitely had a huge
influence on the world higurashi says
weapons shape the world they live in and
with that in mind she has a proposition
for kaido so the implication is that now
the whole wana weapons factory stuff
will be brought up showing how truly
horrible the kurozumi have been for wano
i mean we already knew that but this is
just laying it on even thicker we see
kaido saying let's show all those
peace-loving nobles the reality of war
which seems to echo back to his
childhood and how he resented the fact
that the celestial dragons had power to
boss his kingdom around he says one's
worth can only be determined in battle
where everyone is equal and anarchy
reigns free so even though this is a
pretty basic and flawed philosophy for
an antagonist to have that only battle
prowess is valuable despite the fact
that you can obviously be valuable for
cooking navigating and so on it's still
interesting how even within this warped
world view kaido's yearning for equality
is coming through he loves battle
because everyone is equal doesn't matter
if celestial dragons are high status if
he can beat them in a fight then he's
the better one we see kaido and king
talking kaido says yamato mentioned
joyboy and king says odin wanted to open
wano to welcome joyboy we know king was
waiting for joyboy and that he even
thought kaido was joyboy at one point
kaido tells king that he knows who
joyboy and the man king is waiting for
are then we jump back to the present we
get a shot of the clash between kaido
and luffy but also a cp zero getting
away asap reminding us that the marines
may be coming into play soon we see
yamato and momo and momo screams for
flame clouds to come forth we see more
shots of people celebrating at the
festival below inside onigishima we see
a quick shot of kit oda really
emphasizing this future yanko lately we
then jump to rhizo saying the water of
zou will save everyone and in a bit of a
contrast to that we see everyone getting
snatched up by the water or having to
deal with it in some way it starts
falling off the island we see many
characters including a love struck sanji
and hiyori and denjiro this is a very
powerful scene and dangerous is hugging
her saying she's done really well to
have endured everything for so many
moons she's shown crying and gripping
him like i said a really powerful moment
since we know it's been a long and
difficult journey for hiri and after so
long of keeping it all in she can
finally let it all out we also see
orochi's burning head and i'm thinking
what are you doing oda showing us that
can't you just stop showing orochi
please don't tell me he's still not
finished i feel like he should have at
least shown half of the head evaporating
but no it is still a full head we'll see
what happens with that but oda please
don't bring back orochi again and then
props everyone who saw it coming the
water seemingly extinguishes kaido's
flame clouds and so momo doesn't have
the luxury to waste any more time we
jump back to luffy's giant fist in
kaido's dragon mouth kaido asks him what
kind of world luffy wishes to make and
we see luffy's face which is clearly in
anguish again kaido talking luffy and
payne it's like oda purposely wants us
to think that kaido is in a better
position in this exchange but as we'll
soon find out that's only so oda can
reverse our expectations in the last
moment and give us that oh so satisfying
victory but for now momo finally
succeeds in summoning the flame clouds
to yamato surprise back to luffy we see
that luffy's giant fist is not in fact
coming to contact with kaido and he
finally talks back luffy says he wishes
for a world where his friends can eat as
much as they like it's big for luffy to
reveal this and for me now it's all the
more likely that at the end of the story
he'll really want to have this all you
can eat bash with all of his friends
that he made along the way and since we
know kaido loves to eat maybe he'll be
invited but now ore is no longer teasing
us and luffy starts overpowering kaido
luffy wins the exchange and kaido is
sent flying to the ground kaido
remembers the flashback with king for a
second and how he told him that joyboy
will be the man who will be able to beat
kaido one day king smiles and says if
that's true he doesn't think joyboy will
ever appear but of course we know luffy
is joy boy and he did appear and all
this backstory stuff pretty much
guarantees that luffy just won for real
luffy really just beat the man called
the strongest creature in the world and
the yonko with the highest bounty on his
own
wow this is so crazy as if to further
confirm the victory we see some floating
lanterns just as we did before orochi
was taken down saying please vanquish
the scary dragon restore the kozuki clan
we see both momo and luffy tuckered out
and the narrator says 20 years in the
making as if to further solidify luffy's
win here the only thing we're missing is
the box saying luffy won but that could
well come in the following chapter as
it's done before this fight was already
long i think it's safe to say with the
flashback and all the other conventions
that it's really over the one arc after
so many chapters is pretty much over as
well only some epilogue stuff to wrap up
we're told we will be on break next week
but what an amazing chapter to leave off
on i think this epicness can easily hold
us until two weeks from now i am so
grateful to oda for this amazing chapter
for this amazing journey in general it's
truly still unreal to me how far we've
come let me know what you thought of
this epic chapter in the comments smash
that like button if you enjoyed the
video set the fireworks off to celebrate
this insane victory to celebrate juano's
liberation people we are in a brand new
era of one piece right now so be a
smashing pirate king and not a passing
of rochi join the nakama if you haven't
by hitting that subscribe button and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
check out my growing one-piece playlist
that includes videos of all the yonko
warlords admirals mythical zones and
much more linked to that is in the
description thanks so much for watching
and until next time see you space
cowboys